there's no no limited warfare option
when it comes to open conflict with
North Korea we're talking months of
fighting you're gonna see large amounts
of artillery large amounts of munitions
dropped from aircraft from b-52s b1s b2
s you're gonna see a shelling of the
terrain on the Korean Peninsula that you
only see in the movies from World War
two in the Korean War
this is a very brutal very deadly regime
in the event of a military conflict on
the Korean Peninsula we have a situation
where we could potentially be talking
about the 2nd 3rd and 11th largest
economies in the world engage in a
military conflict the scale of fighting
will be greater than anything we've seen
around the world since the Korean War
not just on the Korean Peninsula I think
that there is a general misperception
among the American public as well as
amongst many of my colleagues here on
the hill as well as I believe with the
president of United States that there's
some sort of limited warfare that can
occur with regards to North Korea that
would be you know a surgical strike or a
bloody nose attack that would not result
in mass casualties and that's simply not
true given the fact that there is a 1.2
million man army some 6500 armored
vehicles tanks some 12,000 artillery
pieces chemical weapons some 5000 tons
of chemical weapons the amount of blood
and treasure that will be expended if
war resumes on the Korean Peninsula will
be on a scale that we have not seen
since the Korean War since the the
cessation of hostilities in 1953 from
the very beginning North Korea would
likely fire chemical weapons potentially
thousands if not tens of thousands of
rounds we're talking about 25 million
people in Seoul or from all around the
world not just Korean citizens a
possible 100,000 dead within the first
few days and 10,000 a day after that
from just a conventional attack I I
don't think there needs to be any other
reason
to be concerned about this they've just
that alone and then the US president
president Trump would have to decide how
does he respond to that kind of thing it
has been waiting for the right
conditions in the past 65 years and at
some point when it beams it has the
advantageous position or when it has no
other option
it may very well attack South Korea
seeking to unify the peninsula under the
northern regimes control for one single
purpose and that is to ensure the
survival of the Kim family regime
according to our commanders in Korea
they could fire something in the
neighborhood of five hundred thousand
artillery rounds shells and rockets
within the first hour and continue that
pace for probably several hours South
Korea would of course retaliate using
their artillery to try to suppress the
North Korean artillery fire and so they
would be firing into Pyongyang just as
North Korea would be firing into Seoul
the capital of South Korea unfortunately
I believe that North Korea would be more
likely to actually use biological
weapons than nuclear weapons one
individual or a couple of individuals
could deliver a strategic level attack
on a city density populated area and
expose tens of thousands or even
hundreds of thousands or over a million
people to lethal doses of biological
weapons they're so potent that one or
two people with less than a kilogram for
example of anthrax and a sprayer a
backpack sprayer could deliver over a
million doses lethal doses of anthrax
and kill tens of thousands or even over
a hundred thousand people in just one
attack in fact I think that a military
strike will only reinforce the belief
among North Koreans that they need
nuclear weapons to make sure that they
maintain their sovereignty and their
independence of action in the historical
literature we talked about a concept
called use-it-or-lose-it
as soon as we start attacking North
Korea in a way where they could lose
their weapons they will be tempted to
use them so if we want to destroy his
nuclear weapons he may well start using
them so that he can get some utility
from them and that's an outcome we
really don't want I think most people
would say that peaceful unification of
the Korean Peninsula is the preferred
way of going about this but I think that
North Korea's ambitions are
fundamentally at odds with US policy and
South Korea's policy what I learn on the
ground talking to both military and
civilian leaders is that Kim jong-un is
not someone who is simply going to
disappear you can't buy him off you know
he is there to stay and he is determined
to retaliate in an overwhelming way with
whatever weapons he has at his disposal
we have to understand that trying to
take a humanitarian attack with them
isn't going to get us very far we've got
to be prepared to show them strength for
them to respect us I would argue that we
still have a quite a bit of runway to
try to shape the way he approaches the
nuclear weapons program I think that
sanctions have never been tougher there
are internal stresses in the regime as
the sanctions take hold and the
diplomatic isolation will continue to
damage the regime's ability to gain hard
currency for its weapons programs now I
think we owe it to ourselves and to our
allies and for global peace to let the
maximum pressure work its way on North
Korea
[Music]